(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] You probably
think huskies are a breed
of dog but you're wrong,
they're actually the greatest
college basketball teams
in the world.
- [Voiceover] Mystic doens't
mean having the quality
of magic, it means an
awesome aquarium in Seaport.
- [Voiceover] 95's not
a number close to 100,
it's the worst place to be
stuck in rush hour traffic
behind Massholes.
Lake Compounce isn't a
boring body of water.
It's the name of the nations
oldest continuously operating
amusement park.
- [Voiceover] Dunks has
nothing to do with basketball.
It's where you go for bomb-ass coffee.
- [Voiceover] The sound
is not a type of noise,
it's a beautiful estuary that
covers 1,320 square miles.
- [Voiceover] Whalers are not
the people who hunt whales.
They are the ledgendary ice
hockey team that left Hartford
in 1997 but who will
hopefully return someday soon.
- [Voiceover] Most people
think Connecticut is
just a small state in the northesat
but it's actually the
best place to grow up.